Hey guys, let's talk about money.
You know, there's a lot of guys who pray to
God and ask him to help them financially.
But they are not obeying His Word.
What He says they need to
do when it comes to money.
If that's you, it means that you never learn how
to deal with money in a biblically correct way.
So even if God does bless you with money, it's
like throwing water into a bucket full of holes.
It will not help you.
Money doesn't fix the
root of the problem for a lot of men.
It might actually make their problems bigger,
because they haven't learned how to
work with their money the right way.
And the right way is always God's way.
Do you know who's the smartest person
ever - I mean the wisest - I
mean you can't tell Him anything
at all when it comes to money.
In all history, He's the richest,
more than Elon Musk.
More than Solomon, in all his glory.
Do you know who it is?
It's God.
So if God tells you something about
money, then you need to listen to Him.
Because He knows what He's talking about and
the bible has a great deal to say about money.
And if you're just - man - if you're open
and listen, it will change your life forever.
I'm going to give you 10 biblical financial
principles every man must know and practice.
Let's start with Number One:
Never create debt.
Try your best to live a debt-free life.
You know, as I grew up, my mom - I can just
hear her voice now - she always said "Danie, moet
nooit skuld maak nie." (Afrikaans, my language)
"Daniel, never make debt."
So how do you do that?
How do you live a debt-free life?
Well, you never make debt in the first place.
And if you have debt, you need
to pay it off as fast as you can.
[Proverbs 22:7]
[Romans 13:7]
and here it comes
Verse 8, listen closely
[Romans 13:8]
Owe no one anything.
Who do you owe something right now?
Think about it.
Write it down.
Or what you owe the bank right now?
Don't take that expensive holiday.
Don't buy that new car or that brand of
shoes that you want, that you don't need.
Pay off your debt first.
[Proverbs 22:26-27]
If you want to buy something
that costs a lot of money,
don't just jump in recklessly making debt to buy
this thing, because you'll spend years to pay off
the interest rate, and it'll be high.
And so let's say it's a house, right?
And you'll spend years just paying
off the interest rate itself.
You're not even paying for the house, so
they're basically stealing your money.
So instead of taking this time,
years to pay off the interest rate,
just take that exact same amount of years, save
up the money and then use it for the house.
Never spend money you don't have
on things that you don't need.
I mean, some of you probably heard this before.
It is so simple and yet a lot
of men don't do this.
And for some reason a lot of men
spend this money on the things they don't need.
On people that they're trying to impress,
which is so silly, for me.
You know, Galatians 6:7 says:
There's always, always consequences
to the decisions you make.
Your actions.
So, if you spend money that you don't have, what
do you think is going to happen? That's foolish.
Jesus said in Luke 12:15:
Greed.
Man, the sinful flesh.
Greed is a terrible thing.
Do not be greedy for things that you do not have.
It's dangerous and life is a lot more
than just the material things around you.
You don't need the latest phone or the
newest and best clothes all the time.
You don't need to fit in with what is
trending and buy the latest or newest thing.
You know, I see this in a lot of prosperity
churches where people just go there,
they worship God, not because they love
Him, they want to obey Him, they want
to live life righteously, in holiness,
growing with God, studying His Word...
No.
They're going there because they want
prosperity in this short temporary world.
So they can just spend all the things
- the money - on their fleshly desires.
Live in luxury.
That's selfish.
You know, the Bible actually says in Hebrews 13:5:
[1Timothy 6:6-8]
Ask yourself, right now, are you
content with only food and clothing?
With what God has already given you?
Or do you pray to Him and complain
because you want - want - want - want.
[1Timothy 6:9-10]
Being content with what we have.
It it protects us, you know,
from falling in that trap of
constantly wanting more material stuff.
Because, you know, you can't
get happiness from that.
You can have peace and joy in the
little things of life that God gives you
and you receive your joy, fullness, purpose ...
everything you need, you receive in Jesus Christ.
You get it from Him.
All these other things, that's just a bonus.
Now, the money you do have
you get that from God anyway.
He can take away your job.
He can give you another one.
He can bless you.
And you need to be responsible with
whatever He chooses to give you.
It's a responsibility.
If you don't use it wisely,
He might take what He has given
you, and give it to someone else.
Jesus said in Matthew 25:
Now, listen to what he says.
Verse 28:
[Matthew 25:28]
Now, we know that this verse is talking
about a lot more than just money.
But we can also apply this verse to money,
because everything that we have, including
money, comes from God in the first place, right?
And so we have a responsibility to use it wisely.
So you also have a responsibility to use
your money wisely, and not spend it just
carelessly on things that you do not need.
Now, let's move on to the next one.
Number Three: Invest.
[Proverbs 21:5]
Investing your money can be a way to
increase what you already have, right?
Your wealth.
But also it can financially
secure your future, which is very important.
But, you need to invest wisely, and not take
unnecessary risks.
Grant Cardone said:
You know, there's a lot of guys who say,
well, yeah, I don't know how to do that.
So I'm just going to leave it.
Has it ever occurred to you that
you can educate yourself?
I mean, YouTube is free.
You can read books.
Google or speak to a financial advisor.
And you can even ask AI in the
world that we live in today.
It's ... well, it's interesting.
And it's a little bit - not sure
where the future is leading us - but
why not use the resources that you have?
So I did a test today.
I asked Chad GPT the following question.
What are the best ways to invest money?
Chad GPT said there are many ways to invest
money and the best approach will depend on
your individual financial goals.
Risk tolerance and time horizon.
Here are some common investment options.
One: Stocks.
Investing in stocks involves buying
shares of publicly-traded companies.
Stocks can provide the potential for
high returns over the long term but
they also come with higher
risk than other investments.
Two: Bonds.
Investing in
bonds involves buying debt securities
issued by governments or corporations.
Bonds provide lower returns than stocks but
they are generally considered less risky.
Three: Mutual funds.
A mutual fund is a professionally managed
investment portfolio that pulls money from
multiple investors to buy a diversified
mix of stocks, bonds, and other assets.
Four: Exchange traded funds - ETFs.
ETFs are similar to mutual funds but
they trade like stocks on an exchange.
ETFs provide a convenient way to invest
in a diversified portfolio of assets.
Five: Real estate.
Investing in real estate can provide
long-term growth and income potential,
but it requires more upfront capital and
can be more complex than other investments.
Six: Alternative Investments.
This category includes investments like
commodities, cryptocurrencies, and hedge funds.
Alternative investments can provide
diversification and potentially high returns,
but also come with higher risks and
may not be suitable for all investors.
It's important to know that all investments come
with some level of risk, and it is important to
carefully consider your investment goals and risk
tolerance before making any investment decisions.
It's also a good idea to consult with a financial
advisor or investment professional
to help guide your decisions.
There you go.
I never thought I would live in an
age where AI tells me how to invest money.
Now, let's move on to the next one.
Number Four: Create a monthly
budget and stick to it.
How do you get ahead?
How do you make money?
Well, when it comes down to
it, it is actually very simple.
Your expenses should never
be more than your income.
I'll say it again.
Your expenses should
never be more than your income.
That's how you get ahead.
And to do that, you need to plan ahead.
Having a budget and then you know certain things.
You plan ahead knowing man, next month
my car needs to go in for a service.
So you plan that into your budget.
Jesus said in Luke 14:28.
[Luke 14:28-30]
You know, maybe you're one of
those people who come to the
end of the month or even the
middle and you're like, man,
my bank account, I mean, what happened?
I don't ... I don't understand.
Whatever.. where did everything go?
That used to be me,
because I didn't work with a budget.
And that's probably you, because you
don't work with a budget.
Dave Ramsey said:
You know, when I was younger,
the lifestyle we had was totally
different from the lifestyle people have today.
Today, a lot of people complain they're in debt,
but their lifestyles ... it
looks like someone who's rich.
They eat nice food.
They have nice clothing.
They have all the latest gadgets.
They go out to the restaurants and
they spend their money on all these
things. And yet, they have debt.
And that's because they
want a luxurious lifestyle.
Living in comfort, even if they
don't have the money to do it.
So instead of changing their lifestyle to fit
in with their budget, they make loans which
then of course gets them in financial trouble.
And carry that weight of stress with them every
day, so at the end they can't even enjoy
the comfy lifestyle, luxurious lifestyle,
that they created for themselves because the
stress of the debt is suffocating them every day.
That's why people across the world -
a lot of them - have so much stress.
A lot of it has got to do with debt.
Now, we've come to the end of Part One.
In the next video, we're going to continue
with Part Two, and it's going to be a few
very interesting things that I'm going
to share with you, especially at the end.
So, I'll see you in that video,
and always remember, life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.